Paula Reid is outside the special
counsel's office in Washington
how will the president's reported
efforts to fire Muller affect Muller's
investigation well this could be used as
possible evidence in the special
counsels investigation into whether the
president obstructed justice by trying
to use his job to tamp down the Russia
investigation but if it comes up the
president's lawyers have at least two
really good arguments the first is they
could argue that the president had valid
reasons to think that Muller had
conflicts of interest and they could
also argue that he didn't actually
follow through after he consulted with
his lawyers and of course this news adds
an awkward dynamic to any possible
interview between Muller's team and
Trump it could possibly even spook the
president from wanting to sit down with
them at all because remember the
President does not have to agree to
answer any questions from investigators
but Muller could then subpoena him to
have to testify before a grand jury now
the president's lawyers could refuse
that subpoena try to challenge mullet
Muller's authority to subpoena a sitting
president which could possibly set off a
constitutional crisis Gail
all right Paula thank you very much